quand il ya encore quelques la crap là
si on la craint on veut que notre
conjoint sas nos enfants sages sont
depuis notre frère notre sort des amis
on veut qu'ils sachent pas ce qu'ils
sont peut-être comptés menés ils peuvent
propager
ils veulent pas le faire donc on se
rappelait tout le monde comme employeur
ses jeunes employés mois qui arrivent au
bureau puis qui a croisé un autre
employé chez mon client est ensuite les
bûches ou d'euros il ya peut-être
compter d'autres nous doublerons donc là
je veux qu'il sache qu'il faut que vous
avez jacques santé publique ont donc moi
comme employa j'ai une responsabilité de
m'assurer que tous ceux qui ont pu être
en contact qu'on va prendre des
procédures pour leur permettre de
s'isoler mais la santé publique doit
faire la même chose
donc c'est pas si simple personnes
peinent à faire ce manuellement l'eau
c'est très très long retrouvez tous les
numéros de téléphone comme qu'avec tout
le monde qui au vue qui est chez terrain
donc c'est pour ça que les gouvernements
de près partout dans le monde veulent
utiliser des applications pour cdd à
crasse et qui a vu king puis nous aviser
pour qu'on puisse surtout isoler pour
qu'on peut gérer dans le fond les
risques qu'on peut présenter pour les
autres et aussi à faire le suivi
si la santé publique réalise que dans
cette pression lors il ya plus de corps
mais peut-être qu'on va avoir des
procédures de confinement un peu plus
sérieuse dans ce boulot mais moins là et
qu'on va être capable prendre des
décisions pour mieux maîtriser la
propagation de la pandémie
mais surtout on a isolé des gens quand
maman la mère de 85 ans la semaine
dernière
donc pendant presque deux mois elle
était elle d'y enfermer tout à fait donc
si elle reste complètement isolé pendant
deux mois pendant 12 mois
pendant votre 4 mois parce qu'on m'a
choisi complet pas qu'elle prenne de
risques
qu'est-ce qui va revenir donc les
personnes âgées il devrait être à même
de faire leurs propres choix si elles
veulent prendre des risques même a
préféré prendre le risque de l'attraper
à voudrais pas le propager mais elle
souhaiterait avoir une application pour
réduire à retrouver sa liberté de sa
voiture à conduire peut parfois être
chaud vous avez nous voir on attendait
des masques en prenant les mesures de
distanciation physique mais à
s'imagine pas rester enfermé pendant un
outil aussi pour retrouver notre liberté
ne peut pas les bons compromis compromis
entre les libertés personnelles qui te
fait que à peu près tout le monde on le
constate la chine ou encore voudrais
partager un peu plus d'informations pour
être capable de protéger pour protéger
les autres oui en même temps il ya
évidemment la question des
renseignements personnels qu'on ne veut
pas qui c'est qu'ils soient dispersées à
travers la planète et à travers
l'univers et puis et d'un vous plaît
pour déficit il est impératif donc de
créer un encadrement qui pourrait
justement savoir qu'est-ce qui est dans
qu'est ce qui est pertinent départager
qu'est ce qui n'est pas pertinent de
partager puis avec qui on veut le
partager
donc quel type d'encadrement serait
souhaitable pour un pays comme le canada
on a déjà fait des râles donc les
provinces qui regardent ce type de chose
quand on espère que c'est vraiment pas
de la base qu'une application ils vont
faire des ces choses là
ensuite c'est bien beau de regarder les
taxes sur la vie privée mais c'est tout
environnement un cas comment vous
gouvernez l'usal de cette application
qui veut s'assurer que dans le fond on
dit qu'on va faire ça mais c'est
vraiment ce que l'on fait dans quelque
temps quand on met ça en vigueur en
application tous voudraient avoir des
gens de la société président de la
société civile devra voir des chercheurs
devraient avoir des gens des premières à
la vie privée qui supervise ce que l'on
en fait qu'on fait bien ce qu'on a dit
qu'on en ferait puis quand on aura plus
besoin de bain et qu'on arrête peut-être
de l'utiliser voka des questions à se
poser
ça nécessite une forme de gouvernance
qui est différente notre besoin de ton
avocat comptable qui pérorent ce modeste
et financier qu'on regarde c'est la vie
des gens c'est la liberté c'est les
informations de santé au niveau des
gouvernements pour protéger la
population
les entreprises qui vont choisir ma
chouette mambele j'aime rester dans le
contenu les employés utilisent
l'application là parce que ça va mais
christine parce qu'ils vont pouvoir
résoudre décidé magicien pas travailler
je veux travées de la maison parce que
je suis rouge ou suis jeune et je suis
un risque
mon dieu c'est beau donc ça peut nous
être utile si nombre on doit se donner
les moyens de nous poursuivre nos corps
bureau donc on va devoir demander à
nogent est ce que
quelqu'un à la maison que la coque de ce
culte des seins parce que le site a pas
pu rentrer donc si je suis signé une
déclaration les matins ça peut être
longue et je peux utiliser un acte je
peux développer mes propres d'une
première production d'applications qui
sont développés par le secteur privé
pour gérer qui je laisse rentrer dans le
commerce ou dans le bureau ou au travail
donc des choses qui se font manuellement
on peut vraiment simplifié la vie que
c'est des bons outils qui font l'objet
d'une gouvernance collection développé
par des gens confiance que les pas
regarder que c'est bien fait c'est clair
que ce qui est bien dans un pays que
c'est différent de ce qui est bien dans
une autre
on peut voir comment la chine utilise et
puis comment c'était obligé versus pays
comme ici pour qu'on va suggérer que les
gens vont avoir envie de le faire
puisqu'on va fortement encouragée pour
avoir le 60 % ça soit vraiment utile
pour redonner de la liberté à des gens
comme maman les états unis on a vu
qu'ils ont relâché leur réglementation
en matière de protection de la vie
privée pour permettre donc chaque pays
bas abordent ces standards différents
mais ça serait intéressant que des
minimums pour qu'on puisse le jour où
j'ai envie de retourner en europe ou
quelque chose comme ça que les standards
minimaux dans le gouvernement pour qu on
peut se retrouver une certaine liberté
dans le désastre internationaux
également si je décide d'y aller en
chine chiffre d'affaires que je veux pas
qu'il fasse avec mes informations
mais j'apprendrais au téléphone ce sera
pas complètement connecté avec ce que je
fais ici puis je ferai le choix d y
aller quand même parce que je succès
pour me protéger les accepte le fait
qu'ils font à leur manière mais je
réponds envie pas passé comme ça ici une
dernière question pour vous nous savons
au canada la loi sur la protection des
renseignements personnels et les
documents électroniques
est-ce qu'elle fonctionnerait d'associer
quelles sont ses forces et quelles sont
ses faiblesses dans ce contexte là
actuelle vous diriez je pense que tout
le monde est au courant qu'il ya des
interdits en cours pour la mettre à
niveau et ceux qui
l'utilisent cette loi c'est des gens qui
sont offertes se sont occupés de ces
conversations
donc quand ils font j'ai confiance que
ces gens là qui vont faire une
évaluation de l'impact sur la protection
de la vie privée
bon on considérer notre loi mais bon
considérer les reculs également dans un
monde il ya de l'intelligence
artificielle est dans un monde où on est
en train d'essayer de sauver des vies et
puis de redonner de la liberté aux
individus donc s'il ya la loi et puis
les gens qui vont être assis à la table
pour réfléchir à comment on va faire les
choses qui représente des gens qui
réfléchissent à ces choses là et qu'ils
vont amener dans le fond nous arrivons
ici on travaille là dessus on travaille
là-dessus au fédéral dans les provinces
avant la colline
donc les gens savent ce qui se passe
d'être capable d'utiliser on met des
gens intelligents en place là donc j'ose
espérer qu'ils vont suis convaincu en
fait qu'ils vont faire les bonnes
décisions pour nous tous et nous
recommande l'application convaincu
qu'ils vont avoir considéré les bonnes
préoccupations annemarie huber perdant
présidente de l'institut sud et la
technologie pour l'humain qui fait
partie si je comprends bien de la
fondation de la technologie pour
l'humain qui est basé à paris
donc merci d'avoir accepté cette
interview pour radio canada
international votre institut l'institut
dont vous cette précédente
et bah c'est ici à montréal si je me
trompe pas exactement ça rit ça
s'appelle human technology candidats au
lieu de l'autre
[Rires]
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté
avec jean plaisir à la peau de chagrin à
bout au revoir